what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite for callers and their
managers live together under one roof
play a stop being polite and start
getting creo
this is the champion this Halloween I
dressed up is a real premier league man
hat trick or treat ever since coming to
Barcelona it's been difficult to connect
with Messi
he's never online he just hold on for
one second I want to send this it's
going to be so funny
wait what oh no oh no delete delete
delete delete man I haven't seen Leo
these frustrated since after every
single international tournament the name
our transfer falling through has really
put Messi and a mood this season I don't
think a trip to the pottery shop is
going to solve this one
maybe Messi needs to talk to someone on
his level oh yes this is a very good
idea I will talk to him now
no I meant Ronaldo BK say I should ask
Renato to dinner because he is the only
person who understands you know how it
feels to always be around worst players
are you excited and know everything okay
no look I don't see what's wrong
how many ABS you see how many apps are
eight oh god no no why is that bad my
ninth app is gone I am truly a g9 hab is
that a thing yeah Christiana your phone
blowing up you I don't know this number
have one of the center backs clear that
thank you I think that he's uh actually
Messi's number oh my god no snap shut up
shop I mean whatever I mean what does he
want you know probably Champions League
tips because I have a 127 champions and
he goes and he is like 113 or something
I don't know I don't pay attention to
that stuff now if you excuse me Kareem I
guess I'll see what Leo Messi wants to
talk to me about
Karine I'm pretty sure he thinks I'm
Karim Benzema so Leo Messi has asked me
to dinner what do you think you want to
talk to him about mmm you know to be
honest I don't have many people in my
life who say the truth so they all will
just say Ronaldo you are so great
Ronaldo you are the best Ronaldo you're
not guilty you know things like that but
if Macy says that I'm the best you know
then it must be the truth but I'm sure
he thinks he is the best except for the
looks of course
so Van Dyke you wafer Player of the Year
yeah see is stupid award you know like I
mean please the guy has one good year
but honestly like I honestly I think he
kind of sucks I think he is very good
player
oh yeah yeah I mean of course for sure
he's very good I mean I don't want to
take anything away from him I just mean
like he isn't as good as us but yeah I
mean I totally I know what you're saying
like he's obviously I will tell you the
specials memories they are prism nothing
we can call our own but death and that
small model of barren earth which serves
as a paste and the cover to our bones
today's special is a French onion soup I
will have the goat yeah exactly to me um
I will have the card please Thanks
so here we are
Ronaldo and Messi just having dinner
you know can you believe it see ya right
so uh how dumb are taxes right okay what
was there like a reason you want to have
dinner because I need to eat through our
energy yes obviously but I mean like a
reason to eat with me see okay and to
talk okay but you don't say anything I
like to let my football to the talking
okay then what am I even doing here this
is stupid this was a stupid idea we are
not the same okay I am a brand and you
are just like a a football robot or
something
yeah run away like you ran away from La
Liga as much what did you say I said
thank you thank you see you solved my
problem before I was mad that we did not
get Neymar
but now you have reminded me that the
greatest players have giant egos and are
not fun to play with you are the best
Ronaldo wait I'm the best well no I did
not mean like do you guys hear this Leo
Messi just said I am the best media any
media did you hear this Messi said
Ronaldo is the best that is not what I
meant I heard it as clear as crystal
palace
no just the palace hall well
[Music]
[Music]
I will not promote this cartoon but I
will subscribe to be our football to
support the champions